OK, it's Thursday, which means we do have
jobs numbers in the last week.
One point five million more people have lost
their jobs.
Remember that this is once again a number
that before the Corona virus era would have
been twice the single week new unemployment
claim record, which was about 700000 prior
to coronavirus in one week.
We have blown that out of the water for 13
straight weeks now.
Record job losses peaking, of course, with
six point eight million people losing their
jobs in one week in late March.
Then we saw declining to five million, four
million a week, three million, two million
in the last couple of weeks, about one and
a half million people each week lost their
jobs.
So this brings the total number of jobs lost
during coronavirus to just over 45 million.
Now, to put that number in context, before
the virus pandemic started, the workforce
was believed to be 158 million people.
Forty five million jobs have been lost during
this pandemic in 13 weeks.
And that is about 28 percent of the total
U.S. workforce.
Now, it's very important to know and I have
no interest in hiding from you, obviously,
that some of the people who lost their jobs
have already found new jobs.
So if you want to find good news or maybe
not terrible news.
The job losses are decelerating, meaning each
week we have fewer people losing their jobs.
That's good.
Would be better to completely turn it around.
We also, maybe most importantly, are seeing
that the last two weeks more people found
jobs.
In other words, they went back to work compared
to the number of people who lost their job.
So like even though in the last week, one
point five million more people lost jobs,
slightly more than that went back to work.
So the total number of active unemployed people
actually went down.
It's a very small change.
We went from twenty point six million unemployed.
To twenty point five million unemployed.
OK, so that's important now to say it a different
way.
Forty five million people total have lost
jobs during the pandemic.
But 20 million are currently unemployed, meaning
a large number of people have gone back to
work.
Now, what's the obvious problem?
The problem is we're in the middle of a pandemic.
I know that Donald Trump is pretending as
though the pandemic is over.
A lot of red states are pretending as though
the pandemic is over.
We're going to hear in the voice mail segment
today from someone living in Hawaii.
But we are still in the middle of a pandemic.
The job losses are slowing down, which is
good, but the pandemic is raging and it's
actually worse than it has ever been in many
states.
So here in the United States overall, we are
still finding about 20000 cases a day.
The last few days, it's been more like twenty,
twenty three.
Twenty four thousand cases.
The seven day average of new cases is going
up, actually, and it has been going up for
10 days.
But then you look at specific states, you
look at Texas, you look at Florida, you look
at Arizona and other states, they're spiking
dramatically and they appear to be nowhere
near their peak.
So look at the contacts, right.
If these job no jobs numbers that we are seeing
now are starting to be less bad because some
states are totally wide open.
But corona virus is still raging.
We have one of two possible futures.
Jobs continue to get less bad as way more
people die from corona virus.
Right.
We are to open the jobs improve, but deaths
absolutely get disastrously worse or we are
going to have to shut down again.
At least some states are going to have to
shut down again.
And we are going to see the jobs numbers get
worse again.
Now, we've seen some states like Texas, Texas
is seeing this.
This is the worst week since the beginning
for Texas.
Texas has made it pretty clear under their
Republican governorship that they don't have
an appetite to close down again.
They seem to be taking the approach of it's
going to be what it's going to be.
Protect yourselves.
You don't want to go out.
Don't go out.
But we're opening and we're going to be staying
opening.
What is becoming very clear is until you have
a really effective treatment and or a vaccine,
you can't have both a serious jobs recovery
and limit spread because some stuff needs
to remain closed, some stuff needs to remain
closed.
I'm hopeful that here in Massachusetts, because
we've gone slowly, we have a very moderate
Republican governor here.
He could have acted a little more quickly
early on, Charlie Baker.
But he widely has done a good job.
We've gone.
The planning has been phased and the phasing
has been planned, as I like to say, and we
have gone step by step and it's a slower recovery.
But the point is that hopefully it's a more
permanent recovery that will get us to have
some degree of economic record recovery up
to the point at which we have a vaccine and
or effective, effective treatment.
Excuse me.
And in some states, they are not taking precautions
and they're pretending everything's fine.
And so while their jobs recovery may have
been faster in the immediate they're corona
virus cases and eventually deaths are going
to get really, really bad.
And we would expect to see that probably by
the end of next week.
You would see a lot of the cases from early
this week start tragically translating into
deaths.
So we're going to follow it.
OK